[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
background of Voldemort's daughter
that's right you heard me daughter
delphini now if you've only read the
original books seen the original films
then you're probably completely lost
right now but if you're up to speed on
the cursed child Rowling's Harry Potter
sequel that follows the children of our
favorite protagonists then you might be
a little more privy with regards to
Voldemort's unlikely Offspring The Most
Interesting aspect of all of this
however is that she was purportedly
conceived during the events of the
original books the Harry Potter universe
is Rich with an ever-expanding list of
complex characters and intricate
storylines with each new addition to
Canon adding new layers to the already
vast and fascinating World created by JK
Rowling one such addition is Delfini the
daughter of the dark lord and drumroll
plays the infamous Bellatrix are strange
delfini's existence was revealed in the
play Harry Potter and the cursed child
and her character has been a source of
both Fascination and controversy among
fans of the series one of the main
points of contention for fans is that
the cursed child simply wasn't well done
and its popularity has reflected that
it's marketed as the eighth story a
continuation 19 years post-deathy
Hallows which follows the children of
the characters that we grew up with main
characters include Harry Potter who was
now head of the Department of magical
law enforcement at the ministry of magic
his youngest son Albus Potter who's just
about to embark on his own Journey at
Hogwarts Scorpius Malfoy the son of
Draco Malfoy and of course delphini but
rather than being made into a film
adaptation the cursed child was made
into a two-part play rather than a
feature film the play primarily comes
into scrutiny from Harry Potter fans
because of its disregard for the
traditional Harry Potter Canon though
Rowling has affirmed that the play
should be accepted as part of Canon most
fans simply won't put up with this this
is for a couple of reasons first of all
the storyline truly upsets our
perceptions of the traditional Harry
Potter Universe the notion that
Voldemort could have a child when he was
born entirely devoid of certain emotions
it's just one example of something the
cursed child did that didn't sit well
with fans the next big issue for most
fans is that Rowling didn't write the
play all on her own and because other
people had influence on how the play and
story would turn out it seems to be the
general consensus that they can't truly
be Canon on the front cover it very
clearly reads based on an original news
story by JK Rowling John Tiffany and
Jack Thorne but just for a moment let's
entertain the version of Canon
introduced by the cursed child and the
Absurd notion that Voldemort devoid of
emotion and social graces could possibly
conceive a child with his right hand
woman and Resident Wizarding World
lunatic Bellatrix are strange in this
video we'll delve deeper into the
backgrounds and motivations of delphini
exploring her Origins her actions and
what her character adds to the Harry
Potter universe delfini's conception
occurred sometime in the mid to late
1990s in secret at the Malfoy Manor as I
mentioned earlier this meant that her
birth coincided with the events of the
original books we just never had any
indication of it Delfini who also goes
by Delphi in the cursed child became the
only non-living heir of Salazar
Slytherin after Voldemort died in the
Battle of Hogwarts in 1998. her birth
was kept a secret by her parents because
they feared that their Infamous
reputations would Place her in danger
especially in the event of their deaths
and died they did with both Voldemort
and Bellatrix being killed in the Battle
of Hogwarts this of course left delphini
on her own an orphan that is until she
was reluctantly adopted by euphemia Rao
a pure blood witch from The Rao family
the Rowell family which appears on the
sacred 28 a list of pure blood visiting
families has a somewhat varied history
with one Damocles Raul being a minister
for magic in the 1700s and one Thor
finrael being a known Death Eater
unfortunately there's not much
information out there in Raul but we do
know that she certainly didn't make
dolphin's life easy allegedly only
taking the young orphan in for a
substantial amount of gold eufemia never
cared for delphini tormenting her
further by keeping a pet all gray and
claiming that it cried because it knew
Delfini would meet a sticky end suffice
to say delfini's time with eufemia was
not very positive despite both of her
parents dying while she was still a baby
Delfina began to inherit traits from
both of them as she Grew Older becoming
increasingly cruel sadistic violent
ruthless obsessive manipulative cunning
charismatic and even intelligent the
list goes on the conditions of our
upbringing and being suppressed by her
mother figure probably only made matters
worse to say that Delfini had an unusual
childhood would be an understatement you
see things didn't work out for her like
it did for other young witches and
wizards she had little to no contact
with other children for the duration of
her childhood instead being forced to
invent Imaginary Friends
and by the time she was of age Delfini
didn't get to go to Hogwarts School like
other witches instead she remained at
home I was unwell as a child for a few
years other people got to go I did not
and I imagine this isolation and lack of
normalcy in her life only pushed her
further into dark Pursuits eventually
delphini was paid a visit by her
stepfather rodolf is strange the husband
of Bellatrix no Voldemort in Bellatrix
had died in the Battle of Hogwarts
rodolfus was able to get away with his
life instead being sent to Azkaban
when he got out he tracked delphini down
and informed her of her true identity
her Heritage explaining that she was the
daughter of the former Dark Lord he also
went on to divulge information about the
prophecy he believed she was meant to
fulfill what's a little scandalous about
this whole thing is that rodolfest or
strange was husband to beltrix delphi's
mother but Voldemort was the father
though it is never explicitly stated it
is my feeling that rodolfus was very
much aware of the relations between
Voldemort and Bellatrix I don't think
that he had any objection to it because
the very nature of billetrix and
rodolfus's relationship was almost
political they were both pure Bloods
that came from supremacist families and
for mainly this reason got together
bellatrix's attention being drawn to
Voldemort only meant that rodolfers
would be able to go about his business
without further distractions or
responsibilities in fact Bellatrix being
chosen to produce Offspring with the
dark lord himself was probably a source
of Pride for him he was first and
foremost follower Lord Voldemort and a
husband to Bellatrix second after
hearing the news of her father's true
identity Delfini made it her goal to
bring her father back to Power helping
him to fulfill his plan for a world
ruled by pure blood Wizards I'm not
going to sit here and just regurgitate
the entire story of the cursed child but
I will tell you delphiny's role and how
she interacted with some of the other
main characters in the story here's a
rough summary Delphi degree used to
confront his charm on Amos degree to
make him believe she was his niece and
to do her bidding she convinced him to
ask Harry Potter to go back in time to
save Cedric Diggory who was killed by
Voldemort Harry refused but his son
Albus overheard and with Scorpius Malfoy
decided to help they stole a Time Turner
altered past events and created two
alternative realities after many
attempts Scorpius managed to restore the
correct timeline and decided to destroy
the time Turner Alba sent an owl to
Delphi to explain they could not save
Cedric
Delphi arrived at Hogwarts that
destroyed the time Turner together and
she revealed her true colors Delphi took
albison Scorpius back in time with her
but they refused to cooperate Delphi
intended to stop Voldemort from killing
Harry's parents but Albus and Scorpius
managed to grab the time Turner and they
raced through time once again they
discovered Delphi was Tom Riddle's
daughter and was planning to restore him
to power Harry and the others helped
Albus and Scorpius and they hidden a
church waiting for Delphi Harry
disguised himself as a Voldemort and
lured her into a trap they overpowered
Delphi and Harry told her she must learn
to live with the fact that she will
always be an orphan along the way Delphi
murdered Craig Boca Jr a student at
Hogwarts for her crimes it's likely that
she was imprisoned in Azkaban of course
there's a lot more to the story but
that's a brief summary it has always
seemed unusual to me that Voldemort
wanted a daughter particularly because
he always seemed so focused on himself
and his pursuit of power but one thought
that I had on this was the perhaps he
merely wanted a daughter to carry on the
bloodline of his ancestor Salazar
Slytherin which would have been
impossible without some form of
procreation perhaps for that reason for
that reason alone Voldemort decided that
having offspring would be a good idea
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live